let's get cracking like I said I hope it
was like a gentle enough introduction
like oh please um let's a look through
so sometimes miss Nikki right and this
will happen more and more as you go
further into the course particularly
when we get to emotion but I just you
know you have a look at this one the
first question less information will
turn anyway right namely the the
y-intercept is just there now this is
really obvious you all immediately could
say oh that's there but I don't really
need that later on will not become so
obvious I have all this information and
sifting out what's important and what is
insignificant what factor to the
question not as easy as it will look so
just there you go you've got intuitive
you pop it in x equals 3 and s you value
we come here it's just straightforward
question room are you happy with that
sound good oh sorry you're talking about
denominator i name you come you talking
about Jim handy right here's the perfect
for so so the question was obviously
when you're doing your v u dash you V
Dash and then there's your B squared
right should I bother expanding out this
actual denominator you can clearly see
what I think the answer probably is okay
i'm generally it is better to keep it
simplified so i keep it factorized
because you gain subversive you gain
nothing out of expanding and in fact you
know for instance if i were using this
for something else you know this means i
noticed that there is one vertical
asymptote right for sorry there's one
point where there is a discontinuity in
the first derivative right if i expand
that out it becomes harder to see that
not easier okay so generally speaking
clivia factorized is fine you don't gain
anything by expanding and as a bonus
sometimes that's useful to me knowing
where the discontinuity
okay good question all right sorry you
may have just slightly ran out of space
here to do this equation is reducible to
a quadratic it's a fairly easy solution
to see that for the exhale to rewrite
that yeah so this kind of two steps
really up for is of course 2 square and
that's being raised to the power X but
by our index laws you can see well
that's 2 to the X square which is what
you just want you to make a quadratic
right once you've reframed it lucky for
you these both get solutions so they're
your solutions having as you come up
possibly one of the most deceptively
simple identities about you look at that
and i bet i bet some of you you didn't
prepare the paper on but something like
oh no which one's the one minus a square
so yes someone you just know some people
look like what I look at it I was like
to do I like make its enough tiniest
sign on Chrome yeah yeah it's like oh
yeah we know a whole bunch of
general-purpose strategies expand
sometimes the most obvious thing is be
easier okay I'm by the way
you're 12 the dead giveaway clue that
you really didn't need to use any form
of verb Pythagorean identity it's just
look carefully at car this and this
relate to each other clearly some Kelly
is going to happen and cancer is exactly
what I'm after right the last who is at
ten in cost Taylor club they they would
go together normally like if I saw some
different configuration which didn't
have the 1 minus something squared I
will just put a time clock together
which as it happens is exactly what you
need all right lastly so here's what the
arm and this is not actually the answer
by the way just part of the answer this
is proper you're working for the ant are
we want the intersection right we want
the intersection so when you have a look
at this in faculty of this way when you
have a look at this you have it region
one became your beneath and you can see
that it's been plotted as dotted because
you're not include the battery then
you've got this guy your absolute value
and you're above because your greater
than or equal to hence the solid line as
well now let's actually finish this
right I want the intersection that means
that both of my regions need to be
satisfied simultaneously okay so that
means you can already rule out like all
of this stuff irrelevant all of this
stuff irrelevant all the businesses
happen in here okay so let's start with
is a point of intersection here and a
point of intersection here you always
start by drawing your points of
intersection as hollow because you can
obviously fill them in later but you
can't unfilled them well I mean you can
but it's just a bit messy so I put them
in as hollow do each of them satisfy
both inequalities look carefully do they
satisfy both inequalities and the answer
is no right I'm they satisfy the orange
one because you've got that solid line
going straight through it okay but they
do not satisfy the purple one it's right
on the purple battery which we just said
is dotted and is not included so I leave
both of them Hollow okay does that make
sense now I have a look
what's happening in here there is and
again i'm going to put it dot it because
if i want to fill it in a second i can
but if i want to feel to be harder is
that boundary included does it satisfy
both it does satisfy both right we
already established its on this line
which is a thumbs up and it's well
within this purple region so i'm going
to fill it Abydos okay last part again
boundary you've got this part of the
parabola here is it in both know it is
not because it's not in the parabola so
that plan is dotted and now I can
actually show you this tiny sliver here
I'm probably missing one last piece of
information the coordinates of my two
points right so i think my coordinates
here are 0-3 and what is its 12 are you
happy with that so it's a very small
area that's a word